i was 28 years old i took him 17 million  dollars in profit and here's two things  that i learned about money that no one  will ever teach you number one is that  money only solves money problems once  you have it you're only left the  problems that money can't solve if you  have a troubled relationship with your  father money's not gonna solve that if  you're insecure money's not gonna solve  that if you can't hold a relationship to  save your life money's not gonna solve  that number two is that anyone who says  that money can't buy happiness is wrong  because they haven't given enough away  because i look back on my life and when  i die i'm probably not gonna care about  the nice condos and the cars and the  jets and all that stuff but i'll just  know that two million dollars went to  help thousands of kids so they could eat  and go to school